Alright, the next topic we're going to get into
is to nail down a concept called PAC learning.
So to do that, we're going to delve into
what the error of a hypothesis is. And there's
two kinds of errors. There's the training error and
the true error. So the training error is on
the training set. What is the fraction of those
examples that are classifieds by some given hypotheses H.
>> Okay.
>> Now H could be different
from the target concept. The target concept ought to have a training error
of zero. But some other hypothesis h might have some error. Okay?
>> Sure, that makes sense.
>> Okay, so the true error is actually the fractions
of examples that would be misclassified on a sample drawn from
D in essentially the infinite limit. So what is the, essentially the probability
that a sample drawn from D Would be mis-classified
by some hypothesis, h.
>> Okay.
>> And we can actually write that mathematically. Error with respect to some
distribution D of some hypothesis h, is the probability that if we draw
the input X from that distribution that you're going to get a mismatch between
the true label, according to the concept,
and the hypothesis that we're currently evaluating.
>> Right, so this sort of captures the notion
that it's okay for you to misclassify examples
you will never ever ever see.
>> Yes, that's right. So we're only being penalized proportional to the
probability of getting that thing wrong. So, for examples that we never
see, that's fine. For examples that we see really really rarely. We
get only a tiny little bit of contribution to the overall error.
>> Okay, I can follow that.